a baseball tournament that's just for
girls will play its championship game
later today in Rockford Illinois 17
teams from the US and Canada traveled
there to play on a field that holds a
special place in the history of women's
baseball for 12 seasons beginning in
1943 Baier stadium was home to the
Rockford peaches an all-female baseball
professional team made famous by the
movie a league of their own
Jericka Duncan talked to some of today's
girls who liked playing hardball not
softball Jericka good morning good
morning Margaret it's been more than 60
years since the all-american girls
professional baseball league ended its
run now women have made great strides
playing professional sports but
tournament organizers say baseball still
remains a few plays behind at Baier
stadium in Rockford Illinois sports
history is being made 200 girls aged 7
to 17 have come here for the largest
girls-only baseball tournament in US
history 15-year old Kendra Levesque
plays third base why is that so
important to be around other girls at
this level because other girls know what
it's like to be a girl playing baseball
and then all-boys team back home they
know the extra work they have to put in
to be as good at better than these boys
I love this game it's the greatest game
winner
Justine Siegel is the tournament
organizer and founder of baseball for
all a group whose mission is to empower
girls through baseball Segal was
inspired by a league of their own
[Music]
the 1992 film about the first
all-american girls professional baseball
league baseball execs created the league
during the Second World War
while many major league players were off
fighting overseas 90 year-old Maybelle
Blair and 84 year-old Shirley bercovich
strike one once played for the all-girls
league we'll never have any Babe Ruth's
in the major leagues and we don't expect
to all we want to do is have a chance to
play our own game they traveled to
Rockford to connect with girls like
Levesque who despite the generation gap
share the same dream these women once
had to play baseball at the professional
level and a lot of people don't think
girls could play baseball so you just
gotta accept that they don't think you
can play and just go and show them
differently on the ball field this month
marks 25 years since the release of a
league of their own and despite being
one of the most successful baseball
movies in history tournament organizers
say little has been done by the major
leagues to create an avenue for girls
wanting to play at that level tarika
thank you very much for that appreciate
it